- What's gooch?
- We the legends of
Chamberlain Heights
- These is our Top 9
Lines for Garbage Time
("We Will Rock You" beat)
- It's garbage time
mother(bleep)ers,
so get your no-playin
asses in the God-damn game!
- Nah, dookie breath. (coughs)
I gots dat affluenza.
- Not today coach, I
got dat 24 hour aids.
- I'm good. If I break a sweat,
then I gotta shower
after the game.
- Man, (bleep) all dat.
I'm not playin till
President Trump
stops spray tannin.
- (Chewing) I'd rather
die on my cheeks than
get garbage time in defeats.
- I'm cool, don't wanna
get the nine all swamped.
- I'm on that injured
reserve. Pulled on my groin
too hard last night.
- Sorry coach, I got a fart
murmur. (stomach growls)
I ain't tryin to shoot no
squirt balls on the court.
- I'm fi'in to exercise
my First Amendment right
to freedom of cheats, hear me?
- Y'all some non-playin'
motha(bleep).
- Nobody likes havin
they they stash messed up
with garbage time minutes.
- Yup! So the next time your
coach tries to play you--
- Play yourself, my nig!
(slap)
- Ahhh!
♪ Legends...what!